[Music]
[Applause]
jim nance remembers augusta with tiger
woods a win for the ages that'll be this
sunday april 10th from 1 to 2 eastern
jim sits down with tiger to look back on
his 25th anniversary of that 1997
masters victory
jim joins us now on the program jim
how you feeling
i'm feeling great especially because i'm
on with you so
good morning and uh
hello friends yeah
how prepared were you for your first
masters
well i thought at the time i was really
prepared it was 1986
i had a pretty deep reservoir of
knowledge in my head
just because i had obsessed over trying
to get to augusta one day but when i got
on property
i was assigned the 16th hole
so i was in a little tower right behind
the green and i try to dig up anything
pertinent to the history of the 16th
hole
and of course i had a lot of background
on what jack nicklaus had done there he
had made a pivotal birdie in 63 when he
won a green jacket for the first time of
course he had that epic day in 75 when
johnny miller and tom weiskopf and
nicholas were all battling and jack made
a like a 40-foot putt
up the hill to a back hole
location
one of the great memories in masters
history so i had all this information
ready to go should the moment ever
arrive
that's a pretty good debut at the
masters jack in 1986
is there a better masters than that it
better masters story
i think it was the most
well listen
it's always going to get back in my mind
to 86 or 2019
when tigers
returned to the top
unfolded no one saw this comeback as
something that was possible but it
happened so jack winning in 86 and just
to finish the story he of course made a
pivotal birdie there in 86 on his way to
winning his sixth green jacket now he
was 46 years old at the time and i can
remember
most people were shocked that he won
because he hadn't won in six years but
on top of it the fact that he was 46
this is insanity how could anyone that
age win the masters
tiger will step on the t
at 10 30 tomorrow at the age of 46.
um
what do you expect out of tiger
i expect him to play well
you never say he's going to go shoot 80
because he's not
i know he hasn't played true competitive
golf since we had that masters in the
fall of of 2020 in november of 20th
that's the last time he played in a real
tournament we're going to not count the
father-son event as a true competition
even though he's played well in him with
charlie but i think tiger
he even said it yesterday the question
for him isn't how we can strike the ball
it's solid i mean fred couples played
with him in these practice rounds and
freddie says it's phenomenal to watch
him hit the ball question's going to be
how does his body hold up walking up and
down the hills this has got a lot of
grade to it and as each day goes on how
much that mounts how much it becomes
more difficult to recover and then
there's this x factor to look out for
and i'm i'm sure you're going to hear a
lot of this in the telecast uh as each
day builds the weather's not going to be
great
it's going to be cold and we're going to
get the rain over with today and maybe
overnight maybe first thing in the
morning it'll be out of here but then
you're talking about
winds
and cold winds it's going to be a high
in the mid 50s on saturday right now is
the forecast it's going to feel like
you're playing in the 40s and that's
that's not easy for anybody but for a
broken down body it's especially not
easy
does he have any say
maybe behind the scenes of who he gets
to play with
no first two no
no none at all uh you don't even get a
say so on your tea time but i think it
worked out favorably for him in this
regard you either when you play a tour
event or a major championship you either
go early one day and late the next on
rounds one and two or you go late early
so i think i don't want to say there was
an accommodation but you had to give
tiger as a five-time champion here you
had to give him a chance to recover from
round one to round two so he's going
early late he's gonna go 10 30 and then
early two o'clock range 210 something
like that on friday which is the right
thing to do
who's he playing with
he's playing with louise hazen
who was in contention at every major
last year and had a couple of close
close calls he's had a close brush with
victory here bubba beat him 10 years ago
in a playoff at augusta and he's playing
with joaquin neiman who i had as one of
my sneaky picks coming in that you don't
really have on your short list he won in
a runaway at riviera this year which is
tiger's tournament the genesis and the
kids got a lot of game and i i know it's
not going to be easy for anyone because
the
the gallery is going to be just so thick
and immense um
and
i don't know what the reaction would be
when you find out you're playing with
tiger you know it's not going to be the
easiest thing in the world because
there's going to be so many people out
there but this is of course this is the
most educated
golf crowd in the world so they'll be
respectful and they won't move
and um we'll see maybe they'll feed off
of all that energy i still like neiman's
chances here
we're talking to jim nance the uh hall
of famer the
win for the ages this sunday at uh one
o'clock april 10th he sits down with
tiger to reflect back on the 25th
anniversary of that historic 1997
masters victory have you ever been to
the champions dinner
no no no no that doesn't it doesn't
quite work that way uh
you have to like you haven't seen it or
anything like you no
no i mean it's not like you call up the
club and say hey can you
you referred me as able to do
um no i haven't been at that one um that
one has a very small audience there's
the chairman of the club in this case of
course fred ridley and then there's all
the past winners that's it there are no
spouses there's no friends of the
champion uh there's no other people that
just hanging on the edges uh it's that's
it that's that's the only guest list
if i said you could sit next to anybody
in that room
foreign yeah
i sit next to my boy freddie there's no
question okay yeah and this is by the
way the 30-year anniversary of uh of
fred's
master's
master's conquest and um
yeah it's i'm excited he's going to play
he wasn't going to play coming here he
hasn't really played more than two
rounds in the last like five months the
back that's been an ongoing issue for
him since 1994
uh has been
particularly prickly here lately and he
he wasn't going to play and he got on
the grounds he was coming here for the
champions dinner and tiger got him to go
out and play nine holes in the practice
round on on monday and he felt good
enough to go so i'm excited for him at
halftime of the north carolina-kansas
game what were you thinking when north
carolina was leading by 15.
i thought kansas was capable
i really did i thought they were really
capable of making a run
but i began to start getting in my head
the story lines
as we would draw near to the end of the
broadcast so what i wanted to make sure
i was going to cover about this north
carolina season and what they've
achieved which it's a it's a long list
of achievements um and then
this is all off camera grant mentions
don't forget the baylor game now he
wasn't saying that as a dookie he was
just saying that as a broadcaster we
have to be mindful of the fact this team
squandered a 25 point second half lead
with 10 minutes to go
and
baylor's furious comeback that
led to overtime and in a restart a
reboot and a win by north carolina which
was pretty amazing
so i thought that's a solid point plus
you've got the fact that in the elite
eight
against miami they turned to switch
and they went crazy i mean they
they ended up outscoring miami by 32
points in the second half that's you
don't see that in in the regional final
so there was like there was an ability
there to see them
making a run
and then you had to think if they did
start to make a run the way they
approach it might be differently than
baylor but it starts it's a i'm talking
about the psychology
hey we've been here we gave up a big
league before it could factor in and you
know they did they i mean they they made
their run early
and next thing you know carolina sticks
down and they came back
so you had this game of runs at the
start it was kansas the whole back half
of the first 20 minutes it was north
carolina in an onslaught then it was
kansas and now you got the last 10
minutes we got to settle in to a back
and forth game without any long runs
so ammo is a great night for basketball
a terrific championship for kansas and i
got to think that you know for north
carolina there's so much to love about
this season the pain is still there it's
still raw
and because you're that close to winning
the championship but the last month if
you go from march 5th to april 4th march
5th was the duke game of cameron and in
that window you're going to beat duke
twice you're going to dance to the
championship game
as an eighth seed i mean it's a pretty
remarkable season by hubert davis and
the tar heels and the north carolina
duke game was a wonderful game in the
tournament and and so we didn't i wasn't
thinking as much as
this could be coach k's last game until
we knew when the game was over that it's
his last game as you're broadcasting it
can you stay how hard is it to stay in
the moment of this is the game not coach
k's last game
i think like you i got lost in the game
i had been with duke every way every
game in the tournament from greenville
south carolina where they were five down
to michigan state with five minutes to
go
turn to switch and won uh and then they
got challenged out west by
by texas tech and then the arkansas game
was
was all duped but
um
yeah i like you i kind of saw
such a back and forth game i wasn't
really stuck on that story but when they
called the timeout with 10 seconds to go
it dawned on me that this might be it i
know i made some remark on the air about
he could be huddling with his team for
the last time and it in fact ended up
being the last time uh caleb love went
down and hit two free throws and made it
a two possession game and it was over
but what a final four i mean new orleans
did a great job
it was it was a big weekend i think for
college basketball we're trying to find
out where it belongs
uh in this crazy stage we're in right
now
all new transfer portals uh nil
where does the college game fit in the
one and done era's been here for a while
can we still love it i mean can we still
like get hooked it's a game that's not
really
well yeah it's about the players it's
always gonna be about the players but
the one constant is the coaches and the
name that's on the front of the uniform
so the quality of talent this is not
um a duke team that was layner hill and
hurley
nor is anyone else
but it's still duke it's still north
carolina it's still kansas
um it's still villanova
and what i found this weekend i walked
away feeling pretty good about it that
college basketball there's viability
there and it's gonna it's it's it's
gonna survive as it still tries to find
out where its places my concern i don't
know if concern's the right word but it
feels like the game is you're either 18
or you're 23.
right that's not gonna change
it's not going to change but you know
what's interesting i'm finding now a lot
of the guys that stick with it
have the pro career still there it used
to be looked at in the early days of one
and done if you didn't leave after your
first year something's wrong with you i
mean for the really premier talent if
you by the sophomore year you've got to
go or it's embarrassing if you stick
around and play years three and four i'm
not talking about you know collegiately
and
scholastically and all that i'm just
talking about nba
um
game planning your life and career i see
guys now that are
that are
five and six-year players
who have been at two or three stops
who i'm sitting next to a guy that's got
an ownership position with the atlanta
logs in the great grand hill
and uh
we we see guys like uh
cam mcgusty
from from um
miami he's in his sixth year
he looks like an nba player to me i
didn't ask him on the air and said grant
can he play he'll definitely be in the
nba he was in the college game for six
years
so we're actually seeing guys that stay
around for a long time there's a guy at
uh this year that was at memphis a very
good player deandre williams
he played uh
played well all season long he's at nba
talent i asked penny hardaway
do you know is he is he going to be in
the nba he said yes the kid has actually
the ability because the covid extra year
he could come back for another year at
memphis i asked him in his last game of
the regular season there's no chance
you're coming back next year he says i
might
he'll be 27.
he's going to be eligible for social
security when he's eligible for the
draft
when's the last time you walk the golf
course at augusta
well it was supposed to be yesterday
but by the time i
got in the car to drive over to the club
uh you could hear the the horns blaring
and they brought everybody off the golf
course so uh it'll be here just a short
while right after this phone call and
this is one of my favorite days i have
had my recovery day you can probably
still hear it in my voice there's still
another good night's rest to get my
voice back after pushing it through 12
12 calls during the tournament and the
final four but uh today
weather permitting that's a big if
uh i i have my annual ritual of going
down to amen corner and uh
walking across hogan bridge
and uh standing on the 12th green
looking around
taking inventory of the world my world
and
walking back across the nelson bridge
with a very full grateful heart how
would you do on the par 312th today
well given that i haven't hit a shot in
about two months
i still think i got it 50 50 i can hit
it on the green okay i'm going eight
iron oh it depends on by the way i'm
going to just hit right over the bunker
i'm not going to go for the flagship
very small now that's one thing we will
not be able to uh answer there is no
chance of walking out there with a club
in my hand dropping a ball okay there's
no chance i want to come back next year
man
i want to be here again you can't get in
trouble down there
well i certainly don't want to test it
to find out but
i'm going to go buy the book i can still
remember my first masters that you
brought up at the beginning
i went in to see the great frank turkini
and as you know he was the father of
golf television and i was just in awe of
him and he tough loved me and he wanted
as time would evolve he told me i want
to make you into what i think a golf
anchor should be so just shut up and
listen to me
i was you know i was a couple years out
of college i mean i was in my 20s
mid-20s when i first showed up at
augusta now i'm in my early 60s so this
has been a big part of my life but i
walked into his office and i said uh mr
turkinian may i ask you a question he
said what is it better be good i said
if someone
makes a hole in one today at 16 i just
walked out there to see the holes today
on the left side where there's a lot of
action
what would i say
he said are you serious i said
yes i am i don't what would i say
he said son
this is a visual medium if you say
anything i'm going to walk out of my
tower and i'm going to come down to the
16th and i'm going to throw you out of
the tower you just shut up and let me do
my job
so i said yes sir now he said get the
hell out of my office and don't be late
for reversal so uh i i
jumped out of his office and took off in
a half sprint this is like a mile away
and i'm off the 18th there's this big uh
land area that that that's between the
8th and the 18th you know that part of
the lawn that's out there and i'm
running to 16 not to be late when i got
stopped by someone from the club and
they said hey hey hey hey what are you
doing and i said i'm trying i can't be
late for rehearsal he said
son
we don't run around here we walk in
augusta i thought okay
that's the last time i've gotten a
warning i don't know if the warning is
still you know two warnings and you're
kicked out of a game
so um i've still got the one earning a
warning it goes back 36 years and i
don't want a second so
i'm gonna go by the rules
great to talk to you great tournament
we'll be uh we'll be watching thanks for
joining us as always bud
bp you're the best love you pal nice jim
nance hello friends remembers augusta uh
tiger woods he sits down with tiger
that'll be on uh cbs this sunday from
one to two eastern as they look back on
1997.